you guys have caught me literally the
last moment of the last scene I'm sad I
can't really process it yet do you want
to let's take a last look with me all
right we're gonna go in for the last
time okay let's go a bittersweet this is
me this is my artwork from college like
a real artwork but they it's a print you
guys like scanned it yeah and there's
another one in these in my bedroom
we had like some of your actual things
like was like oh yes oh yeah my bedroom
is like so my yeah in the hurricane
episode there's like this little
close-up of these little dudes having
their moment you know this story this is
unbelievable I bought a rug okay
in my personal living room and I was
like guys I really want you know a B to
have a new rug and like just a couple
new things to be like oh she's like
older now I tried to differentiate
myself from the character and then I
come in here and I was like that's my
carpet of all the rugs in all
the world they bought the same carpet as
me it makes me almost upset because I'm
like I'm hurt this is my brother and my
dad in real life the Grand Canyon melody
is a teeny Easter egg that we don't pay
off ever all the teeny little touches
are what makes it feel so real I think
that's the fun part kind of like trying
to evolve evolve the sets to match like
what you guys are up to crazy I don't
feel like it's real so I mean we changed
the layout in here to last season like
four was like a big transition so the
bed was in this corner for the first
three season this pink this color of
this room is like crazy
yes it's guava if anybody wants to it's
very koala
wait so this is the thing that in my
actual apartment that I had with markers
just like this and this is like the
recreation of your chair yeah so this is
crazy
first the pilot we brought in my chair
like all this stuff and then they
recreated this chair that's like a very
mid-century retro a vibe it looks so
good like this is not a chair that
exists and I might cry right now but
literally you two have like made the
show like like you have made the tone of
the look of the of every space that
we've entered people like one-hour stuff
and they copy our and it feels real
and you have made the characters feel so
fully fleshed out and honest and like
they actually live in New York City and
so thank you guys really for quitting
your whole it selves into this really
[Laughter]
[Music]